so for years i've been dreaming of this
rig that is such a bad idea i'm just
making his dreams happen
it's literally a gun with a camera on it
so back in the day when sam and i got
our very first red scarlet we didn't
have any money for like rigging all we
had was like a camera body and like a
lens basically what you're looking at
here but the camera body was bigger in
fact the camera body was so big that we
could stuff it into our shoulder it was
like this little pack thing and oddly
enough it was like one of the better
camera rigs i've used since then sam
regularly takes all the gear off the
camera so you can still shoot like that
here's the thing the more i do it the
more i realize that i'm basically just
mimicking the form factor of a rifle
rifles
three points of contact left hand right
hand shoulder it's super stable it's so
stable you can hit a little target from
like 100 meters away so for years i've
been dreaming of this rig something pops
against your shoulder keeps the camera
secure a pistol grip right underneath
the camera to let you hold it steady and
then your hand sits on the camera's lens
and you pull focus
and it's basically the same like pose as
holding a rifle when you're going to
take like really steady shots
but with a camera system the thing about
a rifle design is you notice how there's
a straight line going from where the
barrel and the bullet sits all the way
straight back that's one thing that
makes the modern ar platform stable
perhaps more stable compared to an ak
because if you look at an ak it's not a
straight line going back to your
shoulder it's actually a little bit of a
ridge i think the camera can be a little
off center we just don't want like the
camera sitting on top of a gun we want
to be like part of the body it'll be a
little threatening to our actors and
it's definitely the kind of camera rig
that can get you shot so this is not
something just to walk around with in
public so make sure you get the shot
before you get shot or just make sure
you're not holding something that looks
like a gun in a public space the way i
see this plan out is i'm going to reuse
parts from the huge library of broken
airsoft guns that we already have and
just design some sort of interface
whether that's some sort of mount or
some sort of bracket or something that
will be able to attach that to the
camera some sort of like tripod plate so
i could just take the camera and just
pop it in this is just simply a circular
tripod plate adapter it's this little
guy right here you screw it to the
bottom of your camera and here's the
best part put it your camera into your
tripod plate push it down
pop it locks in and the best part about
this is you can just pop this onto any
rig you want i even have adapter screw
threads here yeah this this actually
kind of simplifies a lot of things the
idea here is that this is going to be
strong so that's another design criteria
is that it has to be strong thank you
for giving me an opportunity to utilize
my engineering degree for now i guess i
gotta go kind of come up with a plan i
would be more involved here
but
i don't have an engineering degree
so now i guess i will go and draw out
what it is i have in mind and from there
i will see what resources we already
have that i can repurpose and then i
will actually start the design process
to make it all happen
so i grabbed a rifle yeah so we have an
ak-47 here
just kidding this is an m16
just kidding this is a bazooka so i was
looking at this one and the main reason
why i decided to go for it because look
at this
but here's what i discovered there's
this pin here
once i take that pin out
everything i don't need comes right off
look at that
this is the thing that holds the
magazine that you slide into place but
what if instead of sliding something
into place from underneath i can baste
the entire mount of this thing
that slides right into that but that
does mean that all of this stuff needs
to come out let's head down to the
workshop
this took a lot more effort to get
disassembled than i was expecting
um i kind of broke it
yeah so tons of screws to get out and it
was hard to get the little like silvery
thing on the inside trying to get that
removed was a pain i eventually did so
the idea is that this would just kind of
attach to the top here and the camera
would sit above it like so now
unfortunately this does kind of raise
the center of mass a little bit so that
it would be a little bit more of that
wobbliness that nico's wanting to
get around so what if i instead
sunk this down to like say here so if i
want to do that and i want to lower this
down i'm going to need to cut this whole
section out right there you do not have
an angle grinder wait do we
this is it
[Music]
so
this is it
obviously i'll need to take a file to
this
yeah there we go that's pretty sweet
there we go now you can access the
screws through the magwell
you know what i think this is it this is
pretty much exactly what nico is after
take your camera
the distance from my face feels
absolutely perfect
i'm just going to go ahead and say that
this is working
one second jake i have to look at
something that is so s
that is so conspicuous i'm gonna shoot
you that is such a bad idea this is like
the war this is they literally have a ar
lower with a freaking camera attached to
it but there's they still have like the
trigger and everything on there like i
would consider this a proof of concept
but nowhere near something i or anyone
else should ever use
it's literally a gun with a camera on it
it was nika's idea i'm just making his
dreams happen
just show it to him
can you see it jake
oh dude
that's fine
anyways all right back to work
thanks jake so now begins the phase
where i actually start trying to figure
out how to mount these two together okay
so i realized something this requires a
better solution than 3d printing it
requires a brand new technology
called wood
basically i'm going to try to make a
magazine out of wood because that will
have the strength that i need to
bolt into it
crap
well time to start over
[Music]
and there we go all right so i have my
block and i have started scoring this
around so i'm just kind of going to take
everything above this line i'm going to
shrink down a little bit
[Music]
reloading
like this really satisfying
i'm going to make two holes that go
through the center of this the bottom
here
[Laughter]
all right this is a quarter inch drill
bit this will be just big enough for the
screws to fit through
oh no dude this is why we need a drill
press
oh dude i'm using this half inch drill
bit and this is like kind of soft wood
so it keeps catching it and it caught it
in just the right way and it twerked out
of my hand and that torque caused the
entire piece to crack guys wren wants to
know your construction tips what's he
doing wrong leave it in the comments
below subscribe no i already know what
i'm doing wrong i don't need to let him
know he needs to be i'm not gonna have
all the opinions dang it man i spent a
lot of time making this piece see this
is why i 3d print stuff because you know
you spend all this time on one little
piece and you make one mistake and the
whole thing is you know done 3d printing
you make a mistake and you just print a
new piece you know what i am actually
really tempted
just to freaking
to model this piece and print it
so that's my decision i'm gonna go model
this and print it tonight so ideally by
tomorrow morning
i will have a 3d print of this exact
piece except working
so i ended up taking this design that i
had crafted and i basically remodeled
this in fusion 360. oh really
let's uh
see how it is oh that came off
dude
that was so easy that was super easy
okay so this is the moment of truth ren
has confidence in his design no i don't
but
it's it's way too it's not fitting it's
not fitting at all
yeah i'm just gonna shorten this a
little bit
and widen these circles
so
this guy is meant to fit a nut look at
that you got it fits perfectly and the
idea for this is that it sits down in
there oh wow so now this can slide right
up into there
all right look at that
just a single bolt is all i needed now
that i know that this is going to work i
just need to adjust the measurements on
the magazine and reprint it
[Music]
moment of truth
[Music]
oh no you got it backwards because you
see how it's like there's this little
indentation i was like okay i'll just
add this little thing
but i added it on the wrong side
[Laughter]
okay i'm just gonna i'm gonna chop this
off hey just take a deep breath before
you use this power cleaner
i think it can get secured
all right this will work
now let's check
screw number one fits
screw number two fits look at that oh my
god this is gonna work this is gonna
work okay
this is it this is like the final moment
you know this is like
this is where everything's been leading
to
[Music]
oh yeah dude
yeah that is secure
dude this is it
[Music]
just got a swing dude yes this fits
perfect look at that
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
look at that high speed low drag oh you
got like a strap for it this is how you
get away with filming without a permit
that lens has to be at least 16 inches
for an overall length of 30. i don't
think that uh is california legal okay
so nico
since you commissioned this project
it is my honor
to give you what you asked for do you
know how many people dream of having a
custom wren engineered rig i don't have
to dream anymore
oh it's so good
this is actually this is great this is
exactly what i was hoping for the camera
yeah actually
quick reload
[Music]
this is the moment we've all been
waiting for an attempt to be a good role
model i tried to put a bunch of bright
colored gaff tape on this that people
wouldn't mistake it as a gun to be fair
we're shooting
in slash on our building so we're not
out of public right now
all right so it's time to put this rig
to the test i have conceived a little
mini scene here that we're going to
shoot as a test for this camera rig i'll
tell you guys how it feels we'll also
get to see how well it performs so wren
here has been striking a deal to get the
goods which peter has in his briefcase
this is some highly highly sought after
goods see the thing is about these goods
is that they typically sell out within
the first couple days so if you don't
get the goods right away you might miss
out this scene i'm shooting it very much
like a little bit like the bourne
identity tony scott style so zoomed in
cameras handheld feel but very telephoto
very zoomed in which usually flies
against the idea of doing something
handheld because the shakiness gets
exaggerated when you're zoomed in
hopefully this rig is going to mitigate
that so this is ideally going to give me
that intense kind of spy movie feel
with a quick and easy to use handheld
rig this is great i like this a lot i
like being able to pull focus and like
move at the same time that's really nice
kind of nice having that strap man yeah
the strap's really nice actually this is
giving me a really unique vibe to my
angles right now and like
the shots i feel like are really stable
like you still have to be a stable
person yourself like
but it's giving me something stable and
it's in my hands and it's quick like i
can let go of it and now it's hanging at
my side i can't do that with the
shoulder mount
so there's definitely like some perks to
having a rig like this i think we chew a
little bit more so i can really make up
my mind
where have you been i've been waiting
here all day
i'm right here don't worry you were like
where are you i was right here yeah do
you have the goods look at my hands
open that up what do you see
here we go these things always sell out
super fast uh-huh yeah they do can i try
it on you know why they call me costco
because everybody gets the sample try it
on oh whoa look at this design it's so
awesome these and all the other designs
are available right now on quarter
digital that store i think we've got a
black friday sale going on right now too
of course better get them quick they do
sell out pretty quickly but fortunately
this box fell off the back of a truck i
bet right who are you talking to
oh
as far as shooting with a prototype goes
like this works really well in my
opinion good i'm glad i'm realizing the
rifle mount's not super versatile like
it doesn't really do any move you want
but as far as like being like a shoulder
mount style mount it works really well
in my opinion it's actually a little
more stable than a shoulder mount it
takes a little more energy because you
have to hold up the weight a little bit
more but the way you pull it into your
shoulder really locks it down like if
you had to adjust to a new subject
really quickly i imagine this allows you
to adjust and
you know move forward really nicely it's
like the goal with this was to give us a
really stable mobile package for a small
film crew basically one man operation
like this is a shoulder mount that boom
it's stable and boom it's off it's not
like it's 20 pounds that you're lifting
off your shoulder it's not like you
can't touch the lens at the same time
but as far as being an operator who's
pulling focus themselves you're
physically using the camera and you want
to get a stable shot like this is very
very so crazy to see
yeah like
this is just a first prototype this is a
far cry from an actual final like piece
of equipment that we'd use so i think
the biggest thing for me right now is
that i want more of the weight to be
centered above the hand right now it's a
little bit in front and that's okay
because your hand is resting on the lens
but i feel like if it was just a little
further back that might be better but
that would start requiring like a more
custom
handle for it rather than literally
utilizing a gun yeah i know the next
thing that has to happen because i know
you're already thinking it we gotta make
the trigger a record button yep
definitely we would love any suggestions
you guys might have on how to improve
this rig and ideas you might have to do
so because i have a feeling this
actually might be very usable in the
future as opposed to just like a one-off
project i think this actually has some
utility that's a nice shirt by the way
where'd you get it
this is one of our new designs honestly
this is my favorite design we've come
out in a very long time something about
this just makes me want to go out into
the woods and track down a robot quarter
digital.store everybody we got a bunch
of brand new designs dropping for this
black friday wait today is black friday
that means the deal is going on right
now go to quarterdigital.store and if
you're actually a part of the website
you get 15 off i'm just saying i think
we have like seven or eight new items we
have a lot of new designs everything
from a breakdown of the halo pistol we
got some boston merch we have hawaiian
shirts back guys this is like this is
the design that everybody's been waiting
for hawaiian shirts are finally back in
the store we look forward to reading you
guys comments we'll see you in the next
video consider subscribing if you're not
thank you so much
so long